our goal is to put the number so high to
where I don't think you got a human on
earth there's a life that can touch it
Birdman Aslam grew up in New Orleans
they were not rich when they were born
they came from under parents background
they were you know coming between boys
homes their dad was sort of in and out
of jail didn't really know their mom
rough upbringing and they wanted to
follow in their dad's footsteps and his
hustlers they say so and they've
discovered a more legitimate way of
doing business in through the music
industry my dad always told us you know
when they just start our own business
and be entrepreneurs he kept putting
that in my head well if you grew up in
New Orleans buddies um whatever you get
into you won't just be a beast about it
you're gonna just be very aggressive
about it if you're hostile you gonna be
a aggressive if you play sports you're
gonna be aggressive I just took the
street life and converted into the music
the aggressiveness of being a hustler
finding ways to turn 1 to 10 10 to 100
it wasn't about just being kosher with
making a few dollars we really wanted to
make some real money in this game
what birdman and slim were doing with
cash money and making the sort of bounce
influence version of hip hop I was
getting so popular regionally that they
were starting to outgrow their actual
regional record distributors before we
even got with Universal right we met
with everybody lot of them refused us
but yeah we had so many demo Simmons
refused us I met with him personally
Leora all those guys they refused us but
we was already making million dollars a
month we was making millions of dollars
independently we refuse to allow
structured deal where they take anything
from us and we came here to Universal
they wanted to do a one-off I'm like man
why would we do that when I say you know
what I'm by the head bachelor on we left
we got up so when we got up though Mars
and Mail come from out the back room
know like what's the problem they many
want to sell company they want us to
do it one off it don't make no sense if
we're gonna do this we're gonna do it
all the way we don't need to do it at
all so he was like I want to sell my
[ __ ] agents so we ended up doing a
distribution deal where it was 8515 and
we all 100% our masses at home what they
not thanked though I think they did it
there wasn't a speck it to happen the
way it did but the same people refused
us to Dave wish they would have signed
us and regret every minute of it I think
the reason the deal was so lucrative is
because for nine months the guys that
cash money let me say no you know they
had put out for six years thirty-one CDs
so they had an amazing track record when
I found them it's not like I invented
them I just happened to find something
that was really kind of amazing and
bring it to the labels and the very
first offer was from penalty records for
juvenile for 75,000 and then nine months
later we were able to get a three
million dollar cash advance and then a
line of credit so that this deal as a
whole equal 30 million dollars and that
was just unheard of for a distribution
deal to get that kind of advance that
worked out really well for Cash Money
founders and have to sell worked out
really well for Universal because they
got the market share that came along
with kind of this fresh sub-genre of hip
hop Drake was brought to the table
drew somebody else I remember Nicky flew
in right after Sam did a call to 3 came
out Wayne played me of music we flew it
to California and they weren't we knew
both former stars you know that's what's
the birth of The Young Money we always
let Drake did what he wanted same thing
we did when Nick it was hard to tell
them people what they're doing how to do
it I wanted a lot to do they wanted to
do they were one of my blessings of
being an artist but you can't paint you
gotta let him paint their own picture
salba - deal what is the current status
wait forever in business with drink wait
for hell my business with drink we
forever business Rudra man we can't we
can't speak up on nothing all I could
tell you is we forever in business with
drink we got a great friendship great
partnership much respect on both sides
of the table and honestly I feel we
forever in business with Drake you know
[ __ ] what you heard of what you might
hear it is what it is we're in business
with Drake something you know they've
they've kind of had a rough track record
on paying folks I'm not sure why that is
it happens to a lot of people in the
music industry but they do have a very
long list of disgruntled people and
folks that have had to sue them I had to
file suit to get paid you know a lot of
people have to get what's owed to them I
think people continue to work with them
in spite of the reputation of
non-payment because they're brilliant
they just have this they have this
unbelievable marketing strategy that
works and they're able to propel artists
to success we make this [ __ ] look easy
but it's really not what if you tried
you'll see try your record company and
see we just make it look easy cuz we've
been doing it for so long and we great
at what we do but I tell anybody who 4c
this [ __ ] in the wrong aspect try and
you'll see what it's built and that's
the problem with today they you know a
lot of people see it they see the
finished product they don't see the work
that going to it before you go to work
with put into it we generated two
billion dollars since we've been in this
company two billion dollars there's some
billion dollar shipment we're forever
ain't never going away
[Music]